what's up you guys movie retrospective
time
so i know that we covered the 1988
remake of the blob which is actually
quite awesome if you haven't seen it
but surprisingly i don't think that we
had ever done the original 1958 blob and
that was the one that won the poll so
now we're talking about it
steve mcqueen's
starring like his first starring role
really i don't think he had done
i think
the funny thing this is what i heard i
don't know if this is true or not
but i heard that he actually wasn't even
in the running to be in this because i
think he was more like known as a stage
actor and not even really that famous
i guess there was a guy whose name i
can't remember who the casting director
or the producer whoever like wanted to
be the lead in this movie and he went to
see this guy
in a play
and
it so happened that steve mcqueen was
that guy's understudy
and so he ended up seeing steve mcqueen
and going hey that guy's great let's put
him in the stage
he got upstaged by steve mcqueen which
you know
if you're going to be upstaged by
somebody it might as well be steve
mcqueen uh so yeah it was cool man he
was cool in real life yeah yeah uh
although i mean obviously he didn't
really um
[Music]
he really fit the part didn't look the
part really well yeah i mean he was
supposed to be 17 uh and he's 28. and
it's you know i'm not being mean but he
actually does look a little bit older
yeah than 28 just in the sense that
people back then tended to look older
yeah nowadays and he looks tough
yeah
that's what kind of role that he's good
at you know yeah
this one is our private investigator
he was kind of something that he was
kind of
in his day a cross between
sylvester stallone and
and uh maybe harrison ford you know what
i mean he
he got those kind of roles yeah that's
really what we what what you're doing
and that was kind of more his strength i
feel like i mean not a high school
student you gotta yeah you gotta start
somewhere uh and he's fine in this he's
actually like pretty fun but
you know you can tell obviously he's not
a teenager so some of the stuff about
ooh let's sneak out meet my girlfriend
like talking to his parents i'm like him
and his parents kind of look like the
same age but yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up
but he was a stallone of the 60s in the
70s
now because he didn't really take this
role all that seriously um
and he didn't think that this movie was
going to be successful uh boy was he
wrong on that
he only took a payment i think it's
either 2500 or 3 000
because he's like hey i got food to buy
and rent to pay like right now they
offered him uh ten percent of the
uh you know theater gross and he's like
no this movie's not gonna damn i know
it's like well you can't really i mean
hindsight's 20. but he's probably like
[ __ ] kicking himself for the rest
he's like i could have been
yeah i could have had 10 of like the
[ __ ] blob which was like a massive
yeah put his name in lights though he
got it back later it did yeah so it's
just kind of like he probably in the
short term he was probably like god damn
it it's like because ten percent of how
much it made i mean i think he was in
one of the best movies ever called
bullet
yeah we did a really good review on that
yeah
real good movie that i hadn't seen up
until recently
yeah and like i said that was kind of
his strength but i feel like
so the blob this kind of came about in
an interesting time it's in color but
came out in 1958
now i'm not entirely sure because i'm
not you know i don't know every film
that came out around this time
but you know because the 1950s that was
sort of like the burgeoning
teen market like you know that you had
to drive in theaters and we feel like
kind of the whole thing where teenagers
were
first seen as sort of like a demographic
that could be marketed to you that had
like disposable income you know what i
mean so there was that there was also
these kind of like films that were
really popular in the 50s that were like
teenage delinquent films you know most
famous one probably being rebel without
a cause but there was like a lot of like
really low budget ones and stuff as well
and obviously the 1950s were real big
for you know alien invader type movies
as far as i'm aware the blob is either
the first film or among the first films
to have combined those two genres and
also might be the first film or among
the first films that made the teenagers
the heroes because as i said prior to
this teenagers and movies were usually
seen as like delinquents they were like
in a biker gang or
you know they were railing against the
man or whatever so they were kind of
seen as like not criminals necessarily
but
you know again like raging
yeah that kind of thing um so this was
kind of the first one
that i think really portrayed and i
don't think they did it on purpose
because i think this was just like a
cheap movie that they made to play in
drive-ins but this is kind of the first
one that went a long way toward
i don't know like
kind of putting the generation gap uh
kind of on the screen you know what i
mean but in a way that like everybody
could understand
because the teenagers are the first ones
to know that something
bad is happening that you know that the
blob is like killing people
but the cops and stuff like that in the
small town like absolutely do not listen
to them and just think they're again a
bunch of delinquents and they're just
making stuff up for sure they can get
pranking
yeah that's what i'm saying that they're
just like making stuff maybe
yeah
which you know
maybe they and also they kind of
established too this isn't like a huge
uh plot point but they do establish that
the crabbiest cop the one that's just
like they just [ __ ]
that that guy uh his wasn't his wife or
somebody in his family was like hit by a
17 year old driver i don't remember if
it killed her or not but so he's like
kind of bitter against teenagers as a
whole and he thinks they're all just a
bunch of hellions it also said he also
he also talks about he has a badass war
record that too yeah so he's a world war
ii veteran these kids today they don't
know he's not old though
no he's 30. that's what i'm saying it's
like everybody in this including like a
lot of the teenagers yeah
look like the same age even though i'm
sure that like a lot of them probably
weren't
but because people looked older back
then like people that were just in their
20s like look like they were in their
30s or 40s like somebody nowadays so i
kind of feel like it's funny because
whenever you see steve mcqueen in there
like talking to like his dad comes and
stuff it's him and his dad don't like
they did actually get like an older dude
like with gray hair like to play his dad
so that's a little more but it still
seems like i mean he's still very
clearly an adult
they're just trying to show the the the
generational differences because yes man
those dudes that [ __ ] went off to
world war ii at 18 came back only a
couple years later [ __ ] prematurely
aged
and drinking themselves to death and
[ __ ]
pissed off that you know that they had
to do that nobody else had to do it and
then yeah you know and then like
the younger generations are now enjoying
the damn middle class lifestyle that was
kind of built on the back of those guys
in world war ii there's a whole thing
about how the government did it [ __ ]
they were trying to re-civilize [ __ ]
a whole civilization or a whole
generation of people coming back from
[ __ ] world war ii trying to get them
out of those cities and putting them in
the damn suburbs there's whole [ __ ]
documentaries on how they did it and
hollywood helped but that's kind of what
they're getting at [ __ ] you know what
i mean that
the kids and this is kind of across the
spectrum of the movies of this era
the teenagers
are
bored
and and pranking and doing [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] because they could they now have
the luxury to do so they they have the
luxury of being bored because they're
growing up in these badass [ __ ]
suburban communities that have
everything kind of handed to them yeah
and they're safe and they're safe so
they don't
toilet paper and houses and dry and
drinking and driving and having parties
and
dressing up to go to a party and that
was
something that the generation the older
generation in those days they didn't
grow up that way
they grew up [ __ ] either
in city apartments
working in factories or out on some farm
without houses and [ __ ] living in checks
which they show a dude living in a shack
yeah the first uh the first victim of
the world is the old guy the old guy who
lives like it back in the 1800s which
really they lived that way up into the
20s and 30s and so mississippi was like
that in the 30s
you know and there were some people that
while the 60s and
60s were rolling around this time people
that old people out on the edges of the
society still lived in those houses like
shotgun shacks with they eventually had
electricity but i guess some of them
didn't have electricity
i love that the guy like i guess well i
thought i was under the impression that
everybody kind of knew who that dude was
maybe because it's like a small town
this was shot in pennsylvania by the way
not a hollywood film at all it's it was
an independent film but um
so the old guy they take him to like the
doctor after the blob gets on because
he's the one that finds uh the meteor
you know that the blob comes out of in a
scene that was homaged later in uh creep
show like the lonesome death of jordy
verrell you know where stephen king's
like meteor [ __ ] they kind of uh shot it
the same way like increasing yeah it was
a lot more than though than this
when you think about the meteor [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was that was stephen king
wasn't it yeah stephen king played that
guy yeah but uh i think the strong point
in this movie
i remember it as a kid saw it on
television uh i think one of the
saturday matinee type monster movies you
know when i was probably about 10
and this movie stuck with me because
it had a credible monster
most old most monsters from monster
movies this era the the the monster was
incredible it had a [ __ ] incredible
alien monster in it just a damn amoeba
basically
me an amoeba that survived in an
asteroid that is all scientifically
plausible
fun facts this is neil degrasse tyson's
favorite movie monster from a scientific
perspective yeah because he thinks it's
it's the most real it's going to be
plausible
like i said yeah he's probably right
about that meteors touch down all the
time
and uh
the the temperatures inside a big meteor
as it [ __ ]
burns up to the atmosphere really don't
get high enough to kill
a lot of micro organisms so
theoretically it could survive that's
why that panspermia
may be plausible between earth mars and
venus materials been traded over the
millions and millions of years so life
may have started on mars and it may have
been delivered here kind of like what
you see in the in this movie but it
wouldn't be a visible this blob when you
see it's the size of an orange
at first at first but then obviously it
gets bigger it's much bigger like as it
eats people right which it does in
reality it would be microscopic you
wouldn't even see it uh that's how it
would arrive
but i'm just saying we we've talked
about many times that in sci-fi movies
the scariest alien to me is the one in
the thing because it can
you know it can mimic anything but the
second scary is probably the blob
because it's just like a gelatinous mass
you can't reason with it and it just
comes to earth and just starts consuming
everything it just gets bigger and
bigger until it like would eventually
take over the whole planet the alien
from squirm
kind of kind of plausible
uh the alien alien from squirm that was
a killer worm movie yeah
no no no not squirm slither from slither
it's kind of plausible a bunch of damn
worms that are in a colony that remember
where they've been
and stuff
and and uh take over
humans and kind of like across it it's
kind of like the thing that you know
what's his name guy from uh
uh uh walking dead is in it uh [ __ ]
what's that guy's name guy from
mississippi
he stars in that one anyway yeah what's
that do you remember that guy's name
yeah i played uh henry yeah i know i
just i can't you can't remember his name
i can't remember someone and then any
and then um another one that's kind of
plausible is uh
the xenomorph something like that yeah i
think that's kind of plausible
i mean more complicated but
yeah so i it's because the alien is
plausible is why it's remembered
only i say against this movie is i
didn't think the theme song matched to
the [ __ ] tone of the movie i think it
needed the theme song was written by
bert bacharach of all people yeah uh
theme song it just doesn't it is it just
doesn't match the tone of the movie it
should have been
something
it should have had just an eerie
kind of although this movie does have
kind of like a little bit of a goofy
tone to it especially in the first yeah
i mean especially in like the first 30
40 minutes because honestly like after
like you have the old guy who i was
gonna say before um i was going to make
i was like trying to say that
it always made me laugh the way like
they took him to the doctor and like
he's just calling him old timer uh and
that guy he's been in like a [ __ ] ton of
other movies and tv shows and he always
plays old man like that doesn't even
have a name or anything like that
yeah he just plays the old man so uh so
he gets killed you know and like people
in the doctor's office get killed but
you don't really see it all that much
and then there's like a 30 minute like
thing in the film where it's just
basically steve mcqueen and his
girlfriend who's played by anita corso
by the way who was helen crump on the
andy griffith show um
she and they're just trying to like
convince the adults that there's
actually something going on that there's
like a monster out there and so
and the cops and the authorities and
their parents and stuff like not
believing them so
there's i do kind of feel like it's a
little bit slow in that area until it
kind of gets to a thing where like the
blob starts attacking like the movie
theater the grocery store or the movie
theater and all that kind of stuff but
you know uh so yeah there's that now so
as i was saying this was actually
originally now this was not a hollywood
film like i said it was an independent
film i believe it was made for maybe a
hundred thousand dollars 120 000 or
something like that
and it was directed by a guy named irvin
yayworth who actually did over 400
movies um that were like motivational
films educational films and religious
films
including he directed a bunch of tv
specials for billy graham the
televangelist which i thought was really
funny so they ended up like raising a
lot of money like i said trying to get
into like the team market and [ __ ] like
that
the idea for the film
interestingly came from
uh the discovery of i guess what back
then they called star jelly
which is kind of like
that you know that gelatinous stuff that
sometimes like falls from the sky or
like they find it in trees and fields
and they're not entirely sure what it is
there's something falls out of damn uh
airplane bathrooms it's probably that's
probably what it is and they're not
entirely sure what it is like it might
be something like biological like some
frog spawn or some [ __ ] like that but
they didn't really know what it was so
it was just like these little gelatinous
blobs so i guess that's kind of where
the idea came from at first that it's
like what if these actually came from
outer space and they were like amoebas
and they started like eating everybody
so the thing about it was that these
globs which have been found kind of like
all over the world there for whatever
reason there's like some folklore that
grew up about them that they only fell
during meteor showers so that's kind of
like where the urban legend is kind of
where the idea for the blob came from
and matter of fact when they were
writing the script the movie was
supposed to be called the molten meteor
uh and then for a time it was called the
glob but then they changed it to blob
and like i said they
i kind of feel like they wanted that
upbeat little theme song because i'm not
really sure why
i kind of i don't know because it is
kind of goofy there is a like a lot of
character like goofy character stuff
like there are scenes in there where
you know like steve mcqueen
they find like him and his girlfriend
right they find the old guy that has the
blob like eating his arm essentially and
they're like hey you know old timer or
whatever let's we'll take we'll take him
to the doctor say take him to the
doctor's office and the doctor says you
should kind of go back to where you
found him at and see if you could find
like some other evidence like to figure
out what what the [ __ ] this is so we can
help him out
and immediately they go out in front of
the doctor's office and there's another
car there with his three friends in
there they're like oh we need to drag
race and i'm like
i'm like do you remember that there's a
guy who's like maybe dying in there and
like in horrible agonizing pain and it's
like you were kind of supposed you had
one job steve mcqueen and uh yeah so he
doesn't do it so there's like a very
very long extended sequence where they
do like a drag race the cars are going
backwards and the cop pulls him over and
he's like trying to like charm his way
out of it and all this other kind of
stuff and he's like oh yeah i forgot we
were supposed to go help that dying old
man
it liked to fake it i was just kind of
like yeah man that's like that's funny i
guess that's what the writers thought
teenagers do yeah i guess
they remember [ __ ] they remember [ __ ]
better than a [ __ ] full-grown person
well that's what i mean and i kind of
feel like if you had seen something as
horrifying as what was left of as what
was eating that dude's hand yeah i'm
kind of feeling like yeah no time to
drag race right now i gotta get i gotta
sort this [ __ ] out because you know the
guy was clearly
uh in a lot of pain and it was funny too
we were like laughing about it because i
feel like the doctor's like looking at
the dude's hand with like all this
[ __ ]
jello [ __ ] on it and it's like probably
we need to amputate that but the guy is
like calling around asking about it
he had to get there
in the books he had to wait till the
nurse shows up those two yeah help him
do it i guess so but i think that's what
he's just calling everybody and i'm like
dude man cut that [ __ ] off it's getting
bigger
yeah i mean he was thinking
procrastinating and telling everybody
about it
yeah come here you got to see this [ __ ]
it's crazy and like they're all flesh at
an amazing rate yeah and
and the old guy's like help me god damn
it it's like probably i was just like
man put a tourniquet on that [ __ ] it's
like
every battlefield [ __ ] soldier
[ __ ] put a tourniquet on it and
[ __ ] clever cut that i mean you'd
think that that was immediately yeah
once you saw once you realized what was
happening yeah then like yeah because
otherwise it's going to consume his
whole entire body and he seemed to twig
onto the fact that it was consuming the
flesh pretty quickly so i was like yeah
at that point
the arm's a loss okay so you might as
well just [ __ ] do that and then like
the nurse gets eaten right although they
don't show that she never
didn't make a scream
yeah she was just like in the office
oh my god because the blob like starts
out like you said about a size of orange
yeah and then like it eats the old guy
and then gets about the size of maybe
like a soccer ball
kind of well i think it got as big as
that guy
i think of the mass it increased it
increased you know it took your mass
remember because when it was on his arm
it was the size of his arm yeah and then
once it was once it is once it absorbed
him it was about the size of a man after
that just kind of in one area rolling
around
i think it just it just converted your
mass and then it was big enough to where
you know the cop eventually says it must
have swallowed 40 or 50 people yeah and
that was about how big and it got redder
too yeah
it was made of effects were pretty good
especially for the time they used some
cartoon animation in certain scenes
miniatures
uh you can see sometimes it's a a small
ball of goo
it's silicone silicone with red dye yeah
you can see it's a small ball and then
behind it is like a cut out photograph
like a postcard and it comes through
like like the movie about the killer
crickets yeah like the giant crickets
was like a building like they have like
a postcard of like buildings in chicago
and then like let crickets like you see
they got [ __ ] pictures of cards and
[ __ ] but you know
i mean it was 1958 it looks it's
charming yeah they don't they didn't
have any money
and that you know what's really clever
actually is that how they got the blob
to move and like look like it was
crawling
was what they would do was they had you
know it's about that big
and so they put it like on
like a card or whatever and then they
put the picture in the back and then
they hooked the camera
to like the floor thing so that when you
tilted it
it would go like that but the camera
wouldn't show that it was tilting so it
looked like it was yeah yeah yeah you
changed the g4 song yeah so that's how
they did it and it's just like i'm like
wow that's a pretty clever idea but like
obviously yeah you can see that
sometimes like it's miniatures and stuff
but that's okay i mean as i said it's
like a great idea for
for a monster you know what's funny is
that the the actual blob that was in the
movie that still exists like a film
collector yeah bought it and still has
it and every year in the town in
pennsylvania where this was shot they
have blob fest because that movie
theater is still there uh that diner is
still there where the the other where
they tried to burn it
that all that shit's still there and
everybody in the town like gets together
to like reenact like the scene where
everybody's screaming and running out of
the theater and that guy always brings
the blob like in a bucket yeah and you
can like have your picture taken with
the actual blob isn't that cool like i
was watching cinemassacre earlier and
james on there he's like a huge fan of
the blob the original blob and he's been
to blobfest before and he's just like
that's the funnest thing ever like
everything is blob related i like the
movie
it is it's it's a fun i mean i'm gonna
say and maybe this is uh a controversial
opinion i like the remake better just
because it's gorier darker more fast
paced
but this one for a 50s movie this is
actually a really fun
50s movie don't expect like a lot of
gore don't expect a lot of i mean it it
suffers from the same thing that a lot
of 50s movies suffer from where it's
just a lot of times it's like people
sitting around talking about [ __ ] um you
know it's not as bad but it's not as bad
as some of the ones because the
characters in this are actually pretty
entertaining yeah they're usually
running from one location to the next
i'm talking about how they're going to
fight stop this thing and
trying to convince adults who are like
oh i can't be but then finally you know
they did he the police chief the police
lieutenant believes him he suspects yeah
he's actually
from from the very beginning he thought
there was something to it
um it's just a good flick the only thing
i would have done is i'm going to change
the direction a little bit
and kind of
maybe toned down some of the
goofiness um but but you know that you
could have kept that uh i think i just
would have changed the the score
and made the score a little bit more
like the thing or like alien and to give
it kind of a more sover kind of a
[ __ ] threatening
tone in the backdrop it
it doesn't have that all the time it's
it's
there are certain scenes where where
like when they're in the meat locker
yeah where you're like okay yeah and
it's like coming under the door sounds
like
and then you think the dog gets eaten
right yeah the dog doesn't get eaten the
dog is fine right um
certain scenes they got it right
but really the opening scenes should
have been
they shouldn't had the blob theme i
would have used that but although i like
that song though this would know what i
would have done
i wouldn't have gotten rid of that yeah
i would have used it as a radio spot
yeah promote the [ __ ]
movie yeah but not really have it in the
movie except in the ending credits
yeah or maybe not even in the ending
credits but just used it as a
as a as a promotion a promotional song
to hype the movie
yeah but when you went to see the movie
it was nothing but just kind of like
something out of alien or something out
of the thing
you know the new thing john carpenter's
a thing
and and i think a score like that would
have [ __ ] been a lot better on this
because this actually does like you said
there are some scenes even though
there's a lot of goofiness in it yeah
it's one it's not as goofy as a lot of
50s movies and there are some scenes in
it that are actually like pretty creepy
and tense yeah like the part like in the
doctor's office like where the nurse
gets eaten the part where they're in the
meat locker and the designer the part
where they're in the diner and they're
like all down in the thing because the
cops are like trying to electrocute the
blob and it doesn't work and then
they're like down in the basement of the
diner that hilarious scene where like um
the girlfriend's little brother within
his little feety pajamas comes out like
runs out and tries to shoot the blob
with his little hop along cassidy pistol
or whatever the [ __ ] yeah i think that's
like really funny that little kid out
there is like hey he's like the bravest
kid ever but yeah i do like that
all the characters in this even though a
lot of them weren't really i mean they
were really really early in their
careers or they weren't like really
professional actors like a lot of them
were local like were local theater
actors or were just like people that and
so there's a lot of face acting yeah
they have like a lot of hometown charm
to them yeah they do and it's it's kind
of like you know when you have the cops
and you have they have little
personality quirks like one like plays
chess with this other guy like this
other cop on the radio and they all have
their own little things that they do and
i just think that there was some good
touches to the extras like with the what
they call them the teenagers they're not
teenagers these are people in their 20s
all right and 30s
um
they had some pretty cool 50s hot rods
with aftermarket paint that was pretty
good for the for the time i didn't let
that yeah that car you could see that
one of those cars kind of had a metallic
or a diamond flake paint job on them
which cars didn't have that until much
later
when you see stock cars what what [ __ ]
was painted with it was terrible looking
paint almost looked like gloss house
paint that's what a lot of cars were
painted with back in the days it was
just
nothing prismatic or deep about those
colors so
but they had that one car that had
looked like diamond flake um and that
paint it was kind of like a cool like
what color would you call that red it
was kind of reddish magenta like reddish
purple yeah it was kind of cool or kind
of pinky right so they had three or four
hot rods that a modern
modern observer who doesn't know the 50s
really wouldn't couldn't really probably
wouldn't really notice that there's any
difference from the other 50s cars but
when you know what
50s [ __ ] stock cars looked if i could
no that's after market [ __ ] you know
what i mean uh and hot rods aftermarket
hot rods um
the
the extras were uh everybody in the
movie is uh good looking too pretty much
out of the out of the uh the teenager
uh uh [ __ ] uh supporting cast uh
girls were cute um which is in all 50s
fashion
the little
50s [ __ ] flat little leather slipper
shoes that they wore and then the
dresses are those big tractors with all
plaid kind of colors on those or
patterns on the skirts and [ __ ] in the
little 50s hair so you know yeah i
thought you know
probably in the day you know what i mean
it would have been a lot of eye candy
for the people for the kids watching it
and teenagers watching it they would
have liked it um i mean i can see why
this was such a big hit yeah and the
thing about it they when they originally
released it it was a double feature
because that's what they did they'd send
out the double features like to every
theater like already put together yeah
and this one was a double feature with i
married a monster from outer space yeah
and interestingly
the the blob was like the second feature
like you know the lesser one but word of
mouth got out about this one so much
that everybody ended up liking this one
a lot more than the other one yeah so
then they started kind of like you know
having this would be the primary feature
or like having it like run by itself
yeah another thing about those days is
that everything was for a general
audience so everything was g-rated
so maybe that's why they have that blob
theme that's kind of light-hearted yeah
so it's not too scary for little kids i
was going to say that that might be why
because you could see from in certain
scenes they knew how to scare you but
they it was really pulling its punches
through the rest of the movie they were
trying to balance it out i believe they
didn't want it to be too scary they're
working to make it not so scary yeah
like scary enough like for a little kid
to be like ooh but like not so scary
that they're going to like be
traumatized for life right if you were
to take and remove that restriction from
that from this movie and just do
put in another score in there
like something out of the thing or alien
you could get this be more scary
without changing a frame
because i mean the idea of being
absorbed by a gelatinous mass is pretty
scary yeah i mean that would be uh
really painful and really horrifying and
just like the idea of it is like pretty
horrifying and it's a mindless alien
creature an amoeba an amoeba that just
absorbs you
you can't reason with it that's what i'm
saying so i think that would be so just
the very idea of it is scary in itself
so maybe that's why maybe they thought
the idea was like too scary and they're
like well we need to lighten it up some
with this like
beware yeah
[Laughter]
i do love that that was like it got up
to number 33 on the charts though it was
like a big like single yeah i was gonna
say two remember when i said earlier
that steve mcqueen
turned down uh ten percent of the of the
gross this movie ended up making four
million dollars in 1958 that's a lot of
money so yeah he would have been a
shoestring budget he would have been set
yeah it cost
like i said i think it was a hundred and
ten thousand hundred twenty thousand
something like that nothing
uh and a lot of it and like i said the
guy that directed it he wasn't really a
film director as such he he directed
like educational movies and like
religious movies and stuff like that he
was a director but he's a good movie he
hadn't really done this type of thing
before it's a good movie you can watch
it to to this day and still interview be
entertained yeah it is still very
entertaining you see the tricks that
they did in the uh you know what kind of
visual effect that is but it doesn't
matter that the movie's
it's it's theater yeah it has a
theatrical tone to it
you know
i wouldn't say it was as good as
as the 1950s war of the worlds
but it holds up
you could play those movies back to back
it's to be satisfied with either one of
them you could put this with uh
forbidden planet which is an expensive
movie this day and it would still just
kind of fit right in with those
and storytelling and the plausibility
and
cast
yeah it doesn't i think the cast goes a
long way and it doesn't look i mean it
looks cheap but it doesn't look so cheap
that it like distracts from the story
like it's obviously low budget but they
did well with the budget that they had
it's colorful
it you know i mean it's colorful it has
certain special effects scenes that are
animated but they look good yeah uh
where the cops shoot the damn
transformer to drop the damn
power lines it looked good when the when
the blobs getting electrocuted it
doesn't look real no but it looks like
artistic yeah it looks good yeah it's
cool looking yeah i mean stop motion
stop motion [ __ ] from [ __ ] clash of
the titans doesn't look real but it
looks good i still love this bike yeah
yeah that was one of his last films yeah
it doesn't look real but it looks good
yeah you know yeah those are two
completely different things two
different things
depending on what you're going for it's
theater yeah and it's art it's not
supposed to be realism real reality
doesn't look good anyway
just just watch some police videos guys
actually shooting each other that does
not look as cool as something that's
what i mean reality generally does not
look very cinematic no it doesn't look
good that's why we have all these
filters and color correcting and special
effects camera angles and cameras where
you have to like tweak everything
because yeah if you just filmed
everything like that everything would
look like crap it looks like crap and
it's not even exciting yeah that's what
i mean so uh so he gets shot and falls
over and dies you go like that's it
because yeah that's it boring yeah
where's the gore yeah come on i want to
see if like get thrown back like that
big spray of blood yeah you wanna i
wanna see the cop an angle of the cop
with the muzzle swinging around and
tearing it down dude [ __ ] with the
dramatic music makes a lot better it
does yeah it does make it a lot better
like i said would you say you know
reality needs like enhancement yeah like
to make it exciting because normal
reality is like pretty boring so they
had the technology back then in the
storytelling to get it done
it's just they didn't really want to
spend the money on sci-fi it didn't have
a big return and just the way the system
was and it was seen as like a kid and
teenager genre yes it's like they
weren't seen as like serious right
movies i kind of feel like sci-fi wasn't
really seen as a serious genre until
probably the 70s yeah same with horror
top-of-the-line top-of-the-line 50s
sci-fi was [ __ ] war of the worlds of
forbidden planet that they spent money
on those which did seem to take them
take sci-fi seriously which a lot of
movies in that era did not right but
yeah i mean this one i although i got i
got to throw in them
about them yeah i like that one that was
a good one too it was black and white
all right and that started the whole
giant [ __ ]
giant animal [ __ ] craze but them was
done right they made some giant [ __ ]
ants they made big-ass ants and then
they had the army out there yeah they
didn't just do like tarantula that had
an actual tarantula but they like a card
on a postcard yeah yeah or they like did
you know the double exposure where it
was like he's crawling around over there
holy [ __ ] like in a totally different
movie
and then they made some big [ __ ]
plastic ants and they
articulated and they moved and
they had him down and what looks like an
underground facility and dudes are
shooting them up with [ __ ] tops of
sub machine guns and stuff we need to
see them
yeah that's another one we haven't done
since we're doing like a lot more 50s
kind of stuff which i like because i
feel like that's a so we've kind of
neglected like a lot of i know we've
done a lot of 70s and 80s and 90s to a
lesser extent done a few 60s movies but
i do kind of feel like we've sort of
neglected them was my dad's favorite
movie when he was a little kid he said
that movie scared the [ __ ] out of him
and he said nothing scared him after
that up until he got to england that was
when he became a man
no i'm saying after that
that said that scared him and nothing
scared him after that until 1970 until
alien came out yeah he said that scared
him then he took me to come see it
he saw it first and then then i saw it
with the second time it was like i see
that that's cool that was what 10 11.
79 that came yes i was nine i [ __ ]
blew my mind nine going on ten blew my
mind i love that movie well see that's i
kind of feel like everybody that's into
horror has that story like the first
time that they saw something that like
really scared them but also that was
like really awesome yeah you know what i
mean see because it like opened up all
the possibilities and then it took me to
see crustal in in in the thing and and
that had him that that got both of us
too
that one
that's a scale you saw that about three
or four times that's a scary movie yeah
i mean yeah so the original blob now the
remake of the blob which also has some
comedy in it too and we talked about
that one before i really like that one
just because
they took the
premise of this gelatinous glob that
eats people and like ran with it and
they just like went all the gore and
special effects and stuff like that and
they sped up the uh you know the pacing
and [ __ ] like that so it's much more
like an 80s action horror yeah with a
lot of gore in it and i think they did a
really good job like updating it um but
i mean the 50s one still has like its
charms especially if you like a lot of
50s movies yeah it is kind of like talky
in the middle and stuff like that but
that's okay like but for the 50s that
was action yeah for the 50s it was a lot
of action and like i said the monster in
it was a really creative monster and a
really scary monster if you think about
it even though it does it's not a scary
movie obviously you can show it to your
kids they'll be fine a lot of a lot of
the 50s the ones she's talking about
where they're just on the phone it's
just white dudes in the office [ __ ]
talking to each other in lab coats or
that and driving cars would be ninety
percent of the damn moving the monster
was only ten percent pretty very end
so this one isn't like that no it's they
are at least running around or or going
somewhere or looking for something or
they're fighting the damn thing or
they're they're fighting the blob
in in certain locations so
by 50 standards this was an action movie
i kind of feel like at ed wood movies i
kind of feel like 80 percent of his
movies are cars pulling up to somewhere
leaving
we have to show a shot of him leaving
because he's going okay and it'll be
like somebody walking to the car getting
in the car pulling out of the gun
i always think of like i can't remember
it was an edward movie it was i don't
remember which one it was um that they
did on mst and like there was a scene
like that and like tom's like film it
all in
yeah i think it's just he just filmed
every single he was he was you know yeah
patting it out yeah they were just
padding the movie yeah the fellas this
one doesn't have a lot of padding you
don't think really not really i mean a
couple little love scenes you might say
they were padding
but they were set ups for things that
happened before so i think yeah it was
pretty good because at the very
beginning i mean it goes right into like
steve mcqueen and his girlfriend like in
the car making out that's like the first
shot right they're not really making out
they made you think that remember
nothing really happens he's trying to
talk his way into it well he's kissing
her yeah that's i guess that's what i
mean by making out yeah because that's
why it's like the first shot and then
they kind of like talk for a second and
then you see like the the meteor fall
and then he's like oh we gotta go like
see what that was well yeah she started
asking how many other girls how many
times he'd been out here yeah there is
that but it's only like a couple minutes
yeah it's always like ah
oh you come out here a lot type of deal
you know he's like ah it's like you're a
man horse
i know he's trying to [ __ ]
try to sidestep that [ __ ]
right but yeah then they kind of go and
but and i know that and then they find
the old guy who has his arm eaten and
then they take that guy to the doctor
and then like i said there's kind of an
extended thing where they do a drag race
when really they should be
you know seeing about the old guy and
the doctor but that's you know yeah when
i saw it in the 70s as a little kid was
absorbing his hand and it's on him
scared me well yeah that's a scary guy
seven or eight and i was like oh man
yeah
so i can understand back in the 50s
it would have been even better
probably yeah because this was really
i don't i can't think of a movie before
this that had an alien like that i mean
because i you know because of budget
constraints and stuff like that they
always had aliens that looked like
people like spacemen they had things or
that looked like yeah or that looked
like you know big bugs like big animals
like you're kind of radiating human face
and some antennas and big teeth yeah
[ __ ] like that or like somebody in a
gorilla suit with a with a diving helmet
on and it obviously doesn't move there's
just a person in there walking
the same facial expression on it the
whole time just it's a suit so the fact
that something could come down and you
just open up a thing and it doesn't look
like it would be harmful it just looks
like jello
or a jujube or something 50s aliens were
never
usually never plausible
you know the basic theme was is that
this planet doesn't have cute teenage
girls on it so they're here for your
cute teenager
that's that's r they're gonna take your
cute teenage girls back to their we just
came here to get a palette load of some
cute yeah
back to our planet our planet who has
none we don't have
and you look at the alien and it looks
like a damn stalagmite on the ground
and it's got a face on it with [ __ ]
lobster claws and it's going to
crossbreed with a human
yeah yeah that was that one
what the [ __ ] that was that was a movie
that was i think that was a roger corman
one yeah where
what was it i think it was it conquered
the world please correct me if i'm wrong
i think it was it conquered the world
where the alien looked essentially like
a spike a zucchini yeah or something or
something with a face on it
and he kind of walked like that yeah
he didn't watch your women he's super
cute
yeah
but it's always something like that you
know
yeah so this might have been the first
time that actually had sort of like a
realistic
yeah there was a more realistic type of
alien that was actually kind of you know
more scary well
the martians from
from war of the worlds i guess you can
see what conor realistic yeah yeah kind
of you looked at that thing you go yeah
it looks like an alien creature
into the three the camera electric eye
yeah
but yeah like i said i kind of feel like
most of them were humanoid or like
robots yeah they're humanoids and robots
and their motivations were totally
unrealistic they're they're here for
women
yeah you know and the blob didn't even
have a motivation he just fell here in
the earth and he's like i'm hungry yeah
i'm gonna start eating like whoever is
around and then not even care about it
it's just an amoeba yeah
but yeah so uh if you haven't seen the
original blob from 1958 it's definitely
worth watching it's super fun uh from
1958 i it's on 2b at the moment to watch
for free uh at least as of this
recording so
go check it out tell us which one you
like better do you like this one do you
like the remake do you like them both i
like them both honestly i do like the
remake a little bit better but just
because i'm you know i like gory [ __ ]
but you know so let us know in the
comments uh and we will see you guys on
the next one
bye